Show you an example of erosion, and
here we're eroding with a disk,
a circular disk,
with the origin in the middle, okay?
So this is the original image,
we saw this one before, and
if we erode with a disk of radius 5, you
can see that what's going to happen is,
first of all of these lines that
are thin, they all go away.
Why do they go away?
They're thinner,
obviously than the size 5.
Or actually it's radius 5.
So they're thinner than size 10.
Alright?
And so, none of,
there's no place you can put that
disk down and have the pixel survive.
Obviously, there's one Stretch
here that's thick enough, and so
that lead survives.
So I make the radius bigger,
this thing, they all go away.
And if I made the radius
even bigger yet,
what happens is all these leads go away.
And also you notice this square
is shrinking by that amount
because the only place.
That you can fit that inside
there is at this level, and
so, it's going to pull
away from the edges.
So that's erosion.
Now, as you saw, dilation fills holes
and stuff, but it grows your picture.
Erosion removes little things
you might not want there, but
it shrinks your picture.
I don't really want to grow or
shrink my cells.
I just want to disconnect them.
Not my cells, the cells in the picture.
So I don't really want the things
to get bigger or smaller.
I just want to clean them up.
Well, so that should make you think
probably I could some eroding followed
by some dilating, or
some dilating followed by some eroding.
And [LAUGH] you'd be exactly right.
And those two operations are referred
to as opening and closing.
And, I say here the two most useful
binary morphology operations.
That is just one man's opinion.
My humble, well okay, my not so
humble opinion that that's
probably the most important thing.
And the only reason I say it's most
important, is in many systems that I've
worked on, a, down in the, in the guts,
somewhere we're doing some opening and
closing just to clean up our
binary images a little bit.